we welcome you back to cbs this morning
an alarming situation is unfolding on
the u.s mexico border
more than 3 200 new unaccompanied
children
hoping to enter the u.s are now in
federal custody that's according to
customs and border protection documents
that were obtained by cbs
news across border activity usually gets
busier this time of the year but this
large number
of younger detainees is particularly
noteworthy maria villareal has been
following the story from the very
beginning and joins us with the latest
mariah this is very very troubling what
we're seeing
gail it's exactly right a former dhs
official says the number of children
currently in border patrol custody is
the highest in the agency's history
now to put this in perspective more than
1500
new children arrived at the border in
the first four days of march
alone mr biden was vice president in
2014 when the u.s saw a comparable surge
of unaccompanied minors
nearly 73 thousand were taken into
custody that year alone
that led to a network of government
supported shelters for minors like this
one in homestead
florida that has now reopened along with
one in carrico springs texas
we were with jacqueline and her mother
miriam as they were reunited
in los angeles yesterday the 16 year old
crossed the rio grande river
in south texas alone and was quickly
picked up by border patrol agents
her mother has been in the u.s for three
years on a work permit and the teen told
us
she was held in a government facility
for three weeks with a lot of other
children sleeping on the floor with
a foil blanket now families we spoke to
say there is a perception right now that
the bidet administration will be more
lenient when it comes to children
crossing into the u.s compared to the
trump administration and that might have
to do with
policy 4-2 42 that is a health emergency
rule that allows border patrol agents to
quickly expel adults
that illegally cross the border because
of health concerns in a pandemic
but that is not being applied to minors
right now the recently opened shelters
have been directed to increase bed space
to pre-pandemic levels
and prepare for the possibility of covet
cases inside those shelters anthony
all right a growing problem down there
maria thank you very much